the jokes are terrible the venue is bad
the fashion was boring okay that that is
unfair the clothing was safe but
tasteful so what are you wearing
this
you look so pretty fashion show fashion
show fashion show at lunch
no fashion show fashion show fashion
show at lunch fashion show fashion show
fashion show at lunch
okay
yes it's too tight way too tight really
this is why I'm here why is it so tight
it's a European cut it just looks bad
um hey
uh what's hanging
set up the webcam for the party oh good
okay cool
how much have you eaten already today
Thunder Mifflin this is Pam
uh just one second we're in a meeting
I'll see if he's available
coach
Michael just rented the Devil Wears
Prada
he has his Netflix sent here to the
office and he watches them in pieces
when things are slow
steak where's my steak he's a big Meryl
Streep fan so I shouldn't be surprised
that he's identified with her character
get me Armani
a suit on the phone like the main
company number because I'm gonna have to
call information where's Armani he's on
the phone too slow you're not going to
Paris I'm so much better than you
I owe you an apology
you finished the movie yeah it was
awesome big surprise ending won't ruin
it for you no go ahead
Meryl Streep is the bad guy you never
see it coming anyway if I was mean in
any way to you
I'm sorry
I just want what's best for you manushka
makushla he's watching Million Dollar
Baby
he's gonna try to kill
you are
good worker and a good man
I just you know
times are tight
and I just don't think corporate's going
to go for this right now
are you wearing lady clothes
what
are you wearing lady clothes those look
like lady pants
no this is a power suit lip is a woman's
suit I do not buy women's clothes would
not make that mistake again I would call
Roy man okay this is gonna make me feel
better this is too good all right you
know what Pam would you please tell
Daryl that this is not a woman's suit
God that's a woman's suit you're wearing
a woman's suit no I do I own I wear
men's suits okay I got this out of a Bim
there were these huge bins of clothes
and everybody was rifling through them
like crazy and I grabbed one
and it fit so I don't think that this is
totally just a woman's suit
the very least it's bisexual
who makes it
um mysterious
and it is mysterious because the buttons
are on the wrong side
that's the mystery it's got shoulder
pads did you see that light okay would
you stop it please oh none of that
tipped you off it's European okay it's a
European cut Michael the pants don't
have any Pockets no they don't see
Italians don't wear pockets it's really
rough couple of days
this helps a little
hey maybe you want to come over and read
my closet no I don't want to do that
because I'm twice your size anyway you
look like Hillary Clinton
um let's just do this in 15 minutes okay
can you stay right there for one second
I gotta send some emails I really love
their outfit
thank you so much for saying that I
can't believe that Toby thinks this is
inappropriate you look like JLo
you don't understand clothing Toby
you're dressed like this amorphous blob
of khaki if I were you I would just
return the Surplus and take the bonus
the what now
branch managers who come in under budget
get 15 of the savings
like a tip
645 dollars I hate disappointing just
one person
and I really hate disappointing everyone
but I love Burlington Coat Factory
you go in there with 645 dollars
you are literally a king
what did we learn this week well one
thanks to me
my team is much much faster at coming to
decisions than I thought they would be
number two never buy a fur coat with a
credit card until you absolutely have
the money to pay for it
and three you should know that some
people think it's cool to throw buckets
of fake blood on you as you are walking
out of Burlington Coat Factory
Michael since it is your 15th
anniversary at the company I thought it
might be appropriate to begin the
festivities with a 15 minute Round of
Applause I like it followed by a
15-minute moment of silence I don't know
is it classy enough Jim enough with the
classy okay I just feel like after 15
years of this company Bravo by the way
that we should celebrate with a very
classy event a night to remember I think
you're right this party has to have all
the excitement drama and Intrigue of my
time here and of course
classy and classy yeah Michael you're
just agreeing with him because he's
wearing a tux don't you see what he's
doing here last week Dwight sent out a
memo about the dress code so this is me
showing him that I'm taking it very
seriously
here we go don't be shine don't be shy
you're one of us fight stall him a
little bit off to get the fish
new boss was coming what no I don't want
to make everybody nervous nope I mean I
could have brought a change of clothes
or you look Dynamite what are you
talking about very slick okay
he just had to wear his tongue
stocks took him 40 minutes to get ready
okay
I'm gonna be at the doll store
close at Gap Kids are just too flashy so
I'm forced to go to the American Girl
store and Order clothes for large
Colonial dolls
she's not supposed to wear white to a
wedding I know but there was an
emergency
I look really good in white
[Applause]
it's a warrior
[Music]
I present to you the rational consumer
as it were
[Music]
true
I don't like your tone look they were
sold out of all the other costumes okay
I think we all live in the real world
here let's not pretend to be unaware of
what cells in these office
foreign